- Kimbap.
- Kim
- [Both] Bap.
- Ow. (laughs)
(uptempo lighthearted music)
(bell rings)
- [Both] Ooh.
- That's not sushi.
But is it sushi?
- This is Korean sushi, I believe.
- I don't eat--
- Sorry.
I tried to get it on the plate.
- I see crab, is that beef, or spam or--
- Uh.
- What the (beep) is going on in this?
- One, two, three.
- That's good,
That's a good time.
- Still chewing dude?
- [Man In Blue Shirt] Sorry.
So good.
- What is going on over there?
- I'm sorry, small mouth.
- It's just the whole
thing is heaven wrapped
in the little roll.
- Mmm.
- It's got some cooked food in there.
With a little bit of spices.
- Is this a fruit?
- There's this really
crunchy aspect to it.
(food crunches)
- Oh, that sound!
- This is some tasty bop right over here.
(air rushing)
- Those look like sausages that have been
basting in kimchi for days.
- This is Korean pasta, right?
It tastes like pasta.
- I've actually made this before.
It's fishcake, this is Tteokk.
Look at me, I'm a little Korean expert.
- It's very good, it's exceptionly chewy.
- It's rice compacted into
this weird space sausage.
- Is there anything inside?
There's nothing inside.
- The spice is telling you to stop,
but your tummy's telling
you to keep going.
- [Voiceover] What, these are cookies?
- Woah, oh wait.
That's not a cookie.
- [Voiceover] Oh my god.
- Oh, it's like a little fishy pie.
- These are fun little things for us.
- Is it an empanada or a pie?
- Oh, it smells like a
ginger bread house, kinda.
- [Both] Whoa!
- Very bready, it's not sweet.
- The craftmanship on this.
- You're a savage.
- I know, I bit into his face.
- Hey, you could probably
make it like other things too.
You could make like a little cat.
Like imagine like Baymax, like this.
- Bean, a little bean max?
- Red bean is just like pure angel.
- Honestly, I'm over the bread.
I just want the red bean.
- I'll never be over the bread.
(air rushing)
- What?
- [Girl In Stripped Shirt] Oh.
Look at these little baby boys.
- Okay, I keep changing
what I think it is.
I thought it was like a grain burrito.
Is this meat?
- It looks like a mix between,
like blood sausage, and rice.
- This kinda looks like little sausage.
Oh, is this blood sausage?
- [Man In Blue Shirt] Put a
little bit of that on there.
- A little sprinkle dinkle.
- I always enjoy a little
bit of salt with my blood.
- I got too much salt.
I ruined what would have
otherwise been pretty a good food.
- I didn't remember
eating Playdoh as child
until this moment.
I'm like, oh I've been here before.
- I can't say I like it.
He's still chewing it and
he put it in his mouth
5 minutes ago.
(hand clapping)
- It's, it's comforting
in a sense, 'cause I,
excuse me, a little blood burp.
- Oh, jesus. (laughs)
- If you were to plate somebody's arm,
that's what it tastes like.
- Oh yeah, a little bit.
- I would eat this again.
- I feel like the sushi's
a solid appetizer.
- Korean food, great.
Korean street food,
even greater.
- Everything, almost everything was good.
- Yeah, certainly.
- You're still, you're
still focused on the guts.
- Yeah, those linger though, those linger.
- They most certainly linger.
- If this food is like pretty inexpensive,
that's great, because Steve
and I are cheap dates.
- That's right, we out!
- We out, we're cheap as (beep).